let's pull the story from Daily Mail
Biden will finally lift coveted
emergencies on May 11th after more than
three years White House urges 14-week
drawdown to deal with title 42 at the
border student loans and hospitals so
that's it he's finally putting an end to
the covid-19 National Emergency I mean
we've been I guess we've been out of the
pandemic for a while restrictions have
been lifted Biden said the pandemic was
over when he toured the Detroit Auto
Show in September right and then the
White House was like no it's not it's
not over it's over now
he's ending it it's it there it is he
says the emergency is over in four
months
can you be sure I thought it were an
emergency no no the emergency is over
okay well it's a 14-week drawdown okay
good that's what it is it's totally
stupid yeah he according to Biden the
pandemic is over it ended last year Well
there we go everybody congratulations we
did it we can go back to doing
everything but you know what I noticed
um you know I I I I I love the casino
out here it's the uh the Hollywood
Casino
when we first moved out here craziest
thing
every table game had plexiglass like you
were talking about Matt they had got to
put the plexiglass and you weren't
allowed to touch any cards this is a
gambler's dream
because that means when you're playing a
table game maybe you're playing uh let's
say Mississippi uh you guys are playing
Mississippi Stud
here's how the game works dealer gives
you two cards there are three cards on
the board that everybody shares and you
gotta pay every time you want to see the
next card hoping that you get a good
enough hand to win your bet it's like if
you get a pair of jacks or better you
win you win money if you know what your
cards the cards your the other players
have your odds increase so you go to the
casino and then everybody's forced to
show their cards it's funny to me like I
don't I don't understand like you're
teaching a kid how to play that's how
you teach a kid to play I'm like all the
gamblers right but you're walking and
you're looking down you're like okay
this guy's got a nice I got a nice I got
there's no ice on the board I fold and
so these these businesses were complying
with policies that made no sense stopped
nothing hurt them substantially but
everybody was just for it but here's the
point I want to bring up aside from that
insanity
they shut down large portions of the
casino
and they've never reopened them really
never why not and and I think for
whatever reason
nobody wants to work
so there's the there's a horse track
there and we went out uh not this
weekend but the previous weekend we went
to the horse races it's so much fun you
guys have to go to the horse races
yeah you you like they have a horse race
every 15 minutes and it's a minute long
thing but you get some food you get a
beer or whatever you bet a dollar on the
horse the silliest name and then you
hope it wins and then you win like a
dollar fifty or something maybe it's a
good time it's a good time it's fun it's
silly and uh but it's outdoor and so we
went there and uh it was funny because
we were there with uh Shane Cashman and
Nancy his wife and uh he bet on this one
horse called like what was it called
like American American prior or
something or American Patriot and when
we were looking at the horses going
around like they're doing the walk-up I
mean the warm-up his is going sideways
and like fighting is like oh no it came
in last oh that's awesome we were
laughing my horse came in first I ended
up winning like 50 bucks but anyway
there's no restaurant you normally you'd
sit and eat food and watch the races
outside and it's so fun one because
every 15 minutes the horses are running
and they said they really want to reopen
it but they can't find anybody nobody
wants it's the weirdest thing Man people
ask me that all the time too do you have
that issue at your restaurant they asked
me hey Matt is it difficult finding
people to work now and I'm like yeah
they're like why is it I'm like I have
no idea it's so weird I I wonder that
too like how is everybody feeding their
families how are people paying their
bills certainly not with eggs where is
this right where's this money coming
from that everybody has well first of
all it was it was ridiculous in in the
beginning of uh the pandemic to pay
people double what they were making to
work to sit at home how in the world is
an employer going to get somebody back
to work come back to work for less than
you're making to sit at home who in the
right mind is going to agree to that but
the reason why people can't find workers
is um is is a question that nobody is
able to answer I have no idea what are
all these people doing I've been asking
this for for what a year now brought it
up on the show and the joke is I mean I
was saying is when Sheamus was here they
got raptured where's everybody where is
everybody how is it that we we we're
still we still have a shortage of
workers nobody wants to work but there's
I mean well hold on Ian you pointed this
out a lot of homeless people yeah a lot
of them are on the street I don't know
the pro I don't have proof that those
that got fired from their jobs are the
ones on the street it makes sense though
even though they're collecting
unemployment and sitting in their you
know the one bedroom employment
unemployment gives out you get like 18
months of unemployment I've always been
like sort of terrified to not have a job
I've been working full-time like
basically since I was 19 years old I
don't know how else you're supposed to
exist like what are you supposed to do I
got unemployment two years a lot of
people seem to be doing that that's a
problem too they they said like I was
that great in 1984 they're like um
football alcohol and gambling are where
are the three like signs of the end of
the civilization especially gambling
football alcohol and gambling I think
those are the three that George Orwell
talks about you and Taylor are with us
right at MGM yeah Taylor won a bunch of
money and I lost three hundred dollars
we went to MGM National Harbor and Libby
just lost every hand and Taylor Sullivan
was Silverman was with us and her first
hand she gets trips on three card poker
and one like a thousand dollars she
would like maybe I made your money back
I'm I'm pretty I have like a real
aversion to gambling it makes me really
nervous because it's so easy and fun but
it's that's the problem with it this is
the thing I think it's a an indicator
an end of a society or civilization the
rampant expanse of gambling and
you know look I love the casino it's fun
it's like an adult arcade you never go
there thinking you're gonna win money
I'm not talking about going and being
like oh boy I'm gonna take my rent money
and vet it and then no no you don't do
that you get a hundred bucks or whatever
and you say we're gonna just play some
fun games minimum bets just for the fun
and excitement then have some food and
go home it's like going to the arcade
you're spending 100 bucks on games no
different than if you went to an Arcane
put 100 bucks in your chip machine so
you can play tokens with your kids or
something but there are people like Mr
Beast who know but there are thousand
people's blindness right except I I go
to the casino and what do I see it's
people milking themselves dry I walk up
to the ATM and I see a receipt true
story saw the receipt and I pulled it
out cause I'm curious like who are these
people betting all this money it's crazy
to me when I sit down I go to the crap
the craps table dice game people forbid
I don't know and I see a dude standing
there and he's got ten thousand dollars
and I'm like who the is this guy to be
gambling 10 grand like that so crazy
well
there's a they this I don't know if this
casino is thought they have a credit
window but it's closed but like National
Harbor's got a credit room you go in
there people are gambling away things
they don't have I pulled I went to the
ATM and there was a receipt hang and I
picked I pulled it out and it said
withdraw 100 of it total available
balance negative 300. meaning yikes they
likely had just gotten paid
withdrew from their paycheck but their
account was previously negative so it
didn't roll over trying to win back the
fee that it's going to charge them for
taking it six dollars for the yep yep I
don't know but I mean
I'm not a conspiracy theorist I don't uh
I don't buy into these conspiracy
theories but I do truly believe that the
uh the government at Large
they do not want to prosperous middle
class and that's evident and I I do
believe that uh one of I'm not saying
the reason for kovid was to kill small
businesses but I do believe that uh it's
one thing that did happen and at the
very least the government saw it happen
and accelerated that process because uh
small businesses were act absolutely
just ravaged during the pandemic well
there was a thing early on and um I
think it was Lansing Michigan it was
like I think it was April of 2020 was it
April anyway it was like right early on
and a whole bunch of small business
owners went to the Capitol and Lansing
uh to protest Gretchen Whitmer and be
like hey you need to let us open up our
nail shops and our hair salons and all
of our little businesses you need to let
us open back up and Whitmer had allowed
casinos to stay open liquor shops to
stay open she allowed big box stores to
stay open and all the little shops had
closed so all these people showed up and
they did like a car protest essentially
and some people went into the capital
you know and they were armed
um they weren't like brandishing their
weapons around or anything like that but
they were armed and everybody freaked
out that these people were there and
they were like you're racist because
you're protesting these lockdown
measures and I remember distinctly there
was one woman who ran a nail shop and
she was like I have employees
I have a family I have a nail shop and
you took it from me like why did you do
this there was a hair shop in Texas and
she refused to close you know and she
kept getting shut down a woman in
Minnesota I think it was southern
Minnesota she had a coffee shop and she
refused so they went after her and she
fled to Iowa I guess and then the
sheriffs came and arrested her for
illegally running a coffee shop yeah
well the thing is you know as a
restaurateur I uh obviously I have a lot
of kids working for me you know minimum
wage kids and the minimum wage is going
up to 15 bucks in Virginia and you just
cannot afford that as a small business
so I mean you're more than doubling what
the minimum wage used to be so as a
business owner I have to I I've got to
increase my prices but as a restaurateur
I can only sell a burger for so much
before you say I'm not paying 20 bucks
for a burger I can only increase it so
much and so that what that does is it
eventually it destroys small businesses
because restaurants
that's the biggest industry as far as
small businesses go in America there was
a little barbecue stand uh not too far
from where we are it's uh where West
Virginia meets Virginia it's gone now I
don't I think someone stole it crazy
someone stole their their cooker and
drove off with it or something like that
and now there's and there wasn't the
waffle stand it's gone I don't know why
it's gone it's sad but we used to go
there and you'd go to the barbecue and I
remember one day we went there I took a
picture I posted on Instagram they said
they had no brisket the cost of beef was
too much yeah and I said well I mean can
you get it and they're like we can but
who's going to want to buy a 20 brisket
sandwich exactly and I was like yeah
I'll take the five dollar chicken
sandwich and and the thing is what
people don't don't realize and I mean
it's the most obvious thing to me is
that minimum wage more than doubles
right but did that person who's making
60 Grand a year
did his salary double no it didn't so
now when businesses have to double their
prices to keep up with the people that
they have to pay to work now you as the
middle wage earner the sixty thousand
dollar the 150 000 now you're poorer
so we lifted the minimum wage and now
the teenagers are getting paid a lot
more money but now you the person that
needs to take care of a family now you
are doing nothing but getting poor and
is killing the middle class and it's and
it's it's so obviously why should you be
paying a 15 an hour to some kid who
doesn't know how to do their job either
like why is that the thing this happens
with minimum minimum wage increases as
well as if it would happen with Ubi
you're a business and you have to pay
whether it's because by government
mandate or by by environmental pressures
15 bucks an hour you're raising your
prices end of story so for like Ubi you
tell everybody you get you get 500 bucks
per week guaranteed
then one day all of your employees quit
all of your all of your stalkers and
cashiers quit and you're like well why
are you quitting and they're like I get
500 bucks a week for for free why should
I work well how much do you want to work
man in order to compete with a free 500
you got to understand this we're not
just talking about the amount of money I
got at the end of the week we're talking
about the equation of how much work do I
have to do for how much reward
if the amount of work I have to do for
Ubi is fill out a form one time and then
I'm done we're talking about
500 per week for the rest of my life add
that up for one minute of work do you
think you're 40 hours of work for even
600 comes close sorry I the people are
going to say I would rather
eat eat out less but not have to work at
all in order if you're doing Ubi or for
if you know free 500 bucks or let's say
it's even 100 bucks
hundred bucks to a young person they're
gonna say 400 bucks a month I'll split
that money with my buddy we'll we'll get
a studio apartment and live for free and
then I'll figure out the rest but now I
don't have to have a job at all and if
you then say we'll give you a hundred
bucks a week if you do this job that way
you're getting twice as much they're
gonna be like yeah but I have the
minimum I need and I don't have to work
so I'm not going to say okay how about
200 bucks a week and they're gonna say
even that you want me to work 40 hours a
week and I or 30 hours a week or
whatever okay
600 bucks a week and they'll say
I mean I guess
an exponential increase in the amount of
money you have to offer because you're
not actually offering them money you're
offering them 40 hours more work they
don't have to do if their needs are kind
of bankrupt not only the economy but
it'll bankrupt Society because there
won't be any innovation
who's who's all for these minimum wage
increases these big corporations the
ones that fund these politicians
campaigns well and that then they they
can put the small businesses out of
business exactly so Walmarts can afford
the 15. how can I right how can I
compete with with Walmart who a teenager
can just go there in stock shelves and
and by the way put their airpods in and
not have to deal with any customers and
listen to music while they're stalking
shows and make 18 bucks an hour and
Walmart can afford that because now they
have like a 50 reduction in Workforce
because they don't even need cashiers
anymore now you're the cashier I hate
that so much I hate that so I cannot
even tell you how much I hate
self-checkout oh my God like I have a
job and now I'm doing this and I was at
the thing the other day with my kid and
we like bought some stupid crap shelf
that then I had to build myself you know
because like I can't even buy anything
to put together and we put it on the I'm
like okay we have to try and get it on
the scanner you you know it's this whole
undertaking of engineering product
project and we don't even realize that
there's like a glass sitting there that
I had already paid for a little
toothpaste Cup and the whole thing the
the Shelf smashes into the glass the
glass goes flying now everything is
smashed and now I have to clean up the
smash glass that I already paid for that
I can't even take home thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time